[Music]
blake is in idaho falls idaho hey blake
what's up
hey how's it going dude great man how
can we help
so i got a question so i'm currently an
apprentice over at a ford dealership
and i got the job offer over and uh
becoming hvac apprentice my dad talked
to me again to that i'm currently making
12.50 an hour i'll be bumped up to 12 uh
16.50 an hour but i'll be happy to go to
school in the fall two nights a week
that's 850.
the thing is too is i have a bunch of
tool to have about a thousand dollars in
tool bed and then a thousand dollars of
debt on a motorcycle i bought you didn't
last
spring so i'm right now in the pinch i'm
like i don't know if i want to take this
job offer and have more school loans to
have or what
okay i got lost somewhere
you're currently doing hvac
uh no i'm currently an apprentice as a
over at a ford dealership right now
apprenticing for what
uh the mechanic as a mechanic and that's
where the tool debt came from
yeah and then the opportunity to move
into hvac tech requires you to go to get
some votech classes is that what you're
saying
yeah and that's working for your father
uh no my father was the one that told me
about getting into hvac and that's what
i'm trying to pursue right now and get
out of the mechanic industry okay
but you're gonna have to pay for these
classes and you don't have the money to
pay for them
yeah my dad said he would help me out
pay for all of it now just pay them back
later down the road from what you told
me no we don't go in debt and we don't
go into dad for sure
bad plan how old are you
i'm 20. okay
why are you doing any of this
i'm trying to get a trade job
why i don't want like a normal just
office job or anything so
you like working with your hands is that
what you're saying
yeah yeah i'm a hands-on type guy that's
good okay
what i don't want you to do is i don't
want you to invest heavily with your
time your life your education into
something just because it sounds like it
might be a good idea to make some money
and that's what this sounds like i've
done
yeah i've done a bunch of research now
watching youtube videos on it looks like
something i could get into because
mechanically now
it doesn't seem like it's really for me
why
it's
pretty much the same thing every day i'm
spending all this money each week on new
tools for a special job and they're just
repetitive
dude
heating and air is repetitive
it's only a couple of times only a
couple things you can do there
yeah but i'm not spending all this money
each week on these tools though
okay but that that's not the question
you don't have to keep spending money on
tools to be a mechanic that's just
something you got sucked into it sounds
like you've got a real good tool
salesman stopping by the shop to me but
um
the uh uh
but but both of these are repetitive
true
yeah we just don't want you to go
through down this hvac path and you go
man i got to buy new tools and this is
really repetitive and i've got to do
something else now after spending all
this money
so i think you've got to take a
breath and figure out what you really
want to do and i'm happy to send you a
copy of ken coleman's book from paycheck
to purpose and i'll also get you the get
clear assessment that he has because i
think right now you just need some
vision for your life i think you need to
take that assessment and really start
asking yourself because i i'll tell you
what i am sure of out of this
conversation after talking to you for
just a minute
i think you're probably uh not only like
working with your hands you're probably
gifted
at things mechanical
it gives you joy to make things work
and you probably need to pursue
something in this field
but i'm not sure you selected
hvac any more carefully than you
selected mechanicing
i think you just saw something different
and you're tired of that one
so
i want you to take those things and then
you decide what you're going to do and
make sure you cash flow whatever
education you pursue you're going to pay
cash for it no debt or don't do it
just don't do it if you have to go in
debt even to your dad george regarding
our last call with that young 20 year
old young man there um earl nightingale
who uh was kind of the grandfather of
the motivational speaking movement back
in the 60s
he used to say in one of his
motivational talks that i listened to
when i was probably that young man's age
that too many people spend more time
picking out
a suit of clothes
than they do their career
and uh
what we're trying to get to there was
you know how many people picked out a
career because their friend got a job
over there
dumb idea
you know people picked out a career
because their mama said you can make
good money doing that dumb idea
you know and so ken coleman and we at
ramsey we spend our lives around here
trying to get you to
find something that aligns with your
talents and your passions
and that is that you're going to get joy
from
and you're going to make money and you
don't go spend a bunch of money on
education then
to become educated to do something that
you don't end up doing
and which is like everybody just about
right so um you know you really need to
parents
uh don't do that to your kid don't say
um oh you make good money heat in there
you gotta go over there uh why
no how about more like um
you have the this unbelievable ability
to see things mechanically
um
and it can lead you to a whole lot of
places yeah it's very important oh yeah
and parents it starts with the parents
and a lot of parents are pressuring
their kids for really terrible reasons
and go to this school because i went
there it's my alma mater and you got to
get this major because then you'll have
a steady job that you'll hate
and then you're going to end up trying
to switch careers and call us going i
hate my job my parents forced me into it
so i just see that future of that bright
young man and i don't want to see him
calling us back on i hate hvac help me
get out of this
i'm not sure hvac's a
a bad thing for him it's certainly not a
bad thing yeah but um the thing the
reason he was describing leaving that
one job is exactly what he's going to
get in the other one so it sounded like
frying pan into the fire to me
so um but it's it's
man you can do so much
in the trades to make money if you want
to go in the trades using your hands
today we love the it's um let's make
that highly recommend them yeah but but
get into something where
you know you have a specific thing that
kind of gives you a little electricity
when you talk about it